fin des années 70 seules les stations de
service public sont légales en réaction
à ce monopole d'état plusieurs stations
pirates voit le jour d'une cave d'un
grenier
elles sont vite sur la bande fm le mode
d'emploi n'est pas compliqué le voici
expliqué par l'un des pionniers des
radios pirates en toile lefébure la
solution la plus simple consiste à
acheter dans le commerce un émetteur
modulation de fréquence aux canaux
rajoute un ampli qui vous permet de
couvrir tout paris en émission sans
aucun problème la première radio
clandestine c'est radio campus en 1969
d'autres suivent comme radio verte
portée par les écologistes en 1977 à
l'origine toujours antoine lefébure le
13 mai elle aimait pour la première fois
à paris elle obtient de nombreux
soutiens dans le monde de la radio mais
certains sourcils c'est pas la bonne
ration de quartier sainte euphémie
feeling c'est complètement imbécile
c'est là l'aberration démocratique
la force de vouloir tout le monde va
parler or malheureusement parler c'est
un art après radio verte d'autres
stations pirates voit le jour la plus
célèbre c'est elle radio riposte
elle est lancée par le parti socialiste
le 28 juin 1979
depuis le siège du ps cité malesherbes à
paris
mais très vite la police investit les
lieux laurent fabius et françois
mitterrand sont même embarqué
nous pensons que la plus grande partie
sinon la totalité
grande majorité des moyens d'information
et les plus puissants sont totalement
dans les mains du pouvoir exécutif et
particulièrement du président de la
république française autres radios
pirates lorraine coeur d'acier qui émet
depuis long oui en meurthe et moselle
dès 1979 à l'origine des militants de la
cgt qui lutte contre les fermetures d
usines de la région mais là encore la
radio est brouillée et des
manifestations dégénèrent le 18 mai
trente personnes sont blessées dont deux
journalistes
quant aux dégâts matériels eh bien
regardez ces images ils sont
considérables
vitrines brisées bâtiments saccagés
toute la journée les services de la
voirie ont nettoyé les rues de longwy
jonchaient de projectiles et de débris
divers lorraine coeur d'acier mais
jusqu'en janvier 1981
quelques mois plus tard françois
mitterrand est élu président de la
république il veut légaliser les radios
pirates à la tête du projet de loi son
ministre de la communication georges
fillioud moi je suis en train de
présenter au nom du gouvernement de la
gauche
un projet de loi qui vise à ouvrir une
liberté qui jusqu'ici étaient interdites
en faveur des petites stations de radio
privées locales cfl le 9 novembre 1981
la loi autorise les stations pirates à
émettre c'est la fin du monopole d'état
[Musique]